دعونا نذهب الى السويد الان قرار مفاجئ
وصادم خرج من هناك لمن راهن على قدره
التقنيه في القضاء على الورق وكتب التعليم
المطبوعه هذا القرار هو خطه الاستبدال
الشاشات اللوحيه والعوده الى استعمال
الدفاتر او الكتب الورقيه طبعا
قبل عشر سنوات تقريبا ولكن وزاره التربيه
والتعليم ووزاره الثقافه في السويد مررت
هذا القرار بان مستوى الطلاب اصبح ضعيفا
جدا في مهارات القراءه والكتابه واكدت
الجهتان ان مخاطر الامر ستؤثر على مستقبل
الطلاب انفسهم وعلى مستقبل السويد ايضا
لهذا تم تخصيص 685 كرون السويدي اي ما
يعادل اكثر من 62 مليون دولار من
الميزانيه لتامين كتب تعليميه للطلاب
ووضع حد لسياسه التحول الرقمي في مدارس
السويد طبعا الاسباب لاتخاذ هذا القرار
راح يطلعنا عليها زميلنا علاء سرحان تفضلي
على شو هي الاسباب صباح الخير صباح الخير
نعم راويه او عادل اذا السويد تعود للكتب
والدفاتر الورقيه في المدارس لانهم وجدوا
ان الاجهزه اللوحيه تشتت الانتباه وتلهيهم
عن التعليم بالدخول لمواقع اخرى ايضا
تدفعهم للاعتماد على مصادر غير موثوقه
للتعلم حيث لا يمكنهم التمييز بين المواقع
الصحيحه والمزيفه من الاسباب ايضا انها
تسهل عمليه الغش وتشعر الطلاب بالعزله حيث
يميلون الى فقد السيطره على كلامهم
وافعالهم لكن ليس الجميع مقتنع بهذه
الاسباب فوفقا لمعلومات موقع ليرنا بلاد
فورد يشهد التعلم الالكتروني ارتفاعا
بمقدار اكثر من 9 مليارات دولار امريكي من
عام 2020 الى 2005
لتقرير تكنوبيو 37 بالمئه من هذا النمو
سيتركز في الولايات المتحده وكندا بحسب
الموقع زاد استخدام الاجهزه الرقميه في
المدارس الامريكيه بنسبه 99% منذ عام 2020
ويقول 58 بالمئه من معلمي المدارس في
الولايات المتحده ان رايهم في التقنيات في
التعليم قد تحسن منذ بدايه كورونا على كل
حال سالنا الناس في السعوديه برايكم ما
الافضل التعليم بالكتب الورقيه ام
بالاجهزه الالكترونيه ولماذا لنتابع
الاجابات
[موسيقى]
الاجهزه الالكترونيه احسها اسهل وتقدر
تتوصل لها بطريقه اسهل انها مثلا تفتح
الجوال او تفتح اللابتوب وعلى طول تذاكر
منه لا تعليم الورقي افضل
بسبب التعليم الورقي يعني الواحد لما
يذاكر هو يذاكر نفسه غير المذاكر مع
الاستاذ فانا اشوف انه يحفظ اكثر احسن من
التعليم الالكتروني دخل معلومه اكثر يعني
تخلي الواحد يركز يقدر يحط ملاحظات عليها
يعني غير احس يعني انا افهم اكثر من الكتب
والورق اكثر من الالكتروني
طبعا الالكتروني ولا اي لحظه يمكن يشحنه
لكن الكتاب ممكن يسافر في المدرسه او يمكن
يضيع عليه التعليم الورق
ي المعلومه اكثر انا صراحه مع التعليم
الالكتروني
تقريبا هو بيسهل لك المعلومه اكثر
[موسيقى]
تنضم الينا الان مشاهدينا في الاستوديو
رئيسه مجلس اداره مدرسه دبي كارمل
الدكتوره مايا الهواري اهلا بك دكتور
يا صباح النور والورد صباح الفل
دكتوره التابلت في مقابل الكتاب الورقي هل
التابلت بالضروره تكون بديل ام انه ممكن
تكون رديف مكمل للكتاب الورقي تمام اولا
صباح الخير صباح الفل بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم والصلاه والسلام على اشرف المرسلين
محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
التابلت دائما مكمل القراءه والكتابه اقرا
اقرا اول كلمه نزلت على محمد صلى الله
عليه وسلم اقرا هي الاساس كيف تقرا هذا
طبعا يتغير مع الزمن ويتغير معمول
والتغيرات القراءه والكتابه والادوات التي
تستحق في المدارس وتسطحب في المناطق
التعليميه
اليوم نحن نتكلم عن اهميه القراءه
تعرفون ان معدل القارئ الطفل 44 كتاب في
السنه
اللي ما يقرا وايد يقول لك 22 كتاب في
معدل التركيز من الفين في عام 2000 كان 15
ثانيه
15.5 ثانيه بعد خمس سنين نزلت الى ثمانيه
فاصل خمسه ثانيه تركيز
تخيل انت اليوم في 2023 لما نتكلم على
التيك توك نتكلم
عنها
معدل الانتباه والتركيز ثلاث ثواني من
اثنين الى ثلاث ثواني اذا في عندنا مشكله
كيف انا هذا الطفل اللي متعود على التابلت
كله انه شيء من اولها يكون جاذب له هني
اللي
يجذب انتباهه كيف انت بتجلسه يقرا حتى 22
كتاب ما وصلهم سنويا فالموضوع محتاج الى
نظره
وتغيير ثوره في القراءه والكتابه هذا
يدفعني الى التفاعل المشكله في التابلت
ولا المشكله في الطالب ولا المشكله في
المنهج او حتى طريقه التعليم ما لانه احنا
استعدنا عن الكتابه بالطباعه القراءه هي
قراءه ولا ان كان ما بين الهارد كوبي يعني
ما بين النسخه التابلت او الكتاب وين
هي مش مشكله هي سبحان الله
يعني كورونا يعني حصل معانا جبار العالم
وجبره الناس انها تدخل على وهذا هذا وهذا
يكون واقعنا فانت عندك في سنتين سنتين
وشوي الين اليوم بالصين تعاني من هذا
الموضوع من الكورونا
عندهم مشكله في ما في الوجهين لوجه نعم
والتواصل فاكيد انت انجبرت واطفالنا
نجبروا والتعليم كله تاثر اليوم في السويد
انهم موقفين خلينا نقول تفضلي يعني موقفين
رد رجعوا الى القراءه والكتابه اكثر مش من
شيء قليل لان في خلال السنتين ونص هذا
اللي طافوا المعدل معدل القراءه وجوده
القراءه والكتابه عند الطفل المنخفضه هل
احنا اخترناه لا اضطرينا عليه هي ظروف
حكمه ولكن يعني انا بحس انه في ظلم
للتابلت نفسه التابلت عباره عن اداه زي ما
الكتاب عباره عن اداه
المشكله في السوشيال ميديا اعتقد والتيك
توك هي اللي بتقصد بالضبط وبالمدرسه لما
يستخدم التابلت ممنوع يعني اولادنا جميعا
بمدارس بيستخدموا تابلت وكمبيوتر
صحيح
منعا باتا انهم يدخلوا على اي سوشيال
ميديا او اي اشي غير لا يتعلق بالموضوع
بالمنهج او بالموضوع اللي عم بيتعلموه
المشكله بعتقد اكثر هي مش مشكله في
القراءه ولكن في الكتابه لانه انت تستطيع
ان تقرا من تابلت او من كتاب ولكن عندما
تكتب الادوات مختلفه قلم او يعني تدوس
الزراير معينه صحيح انا عندي وجهه من هاي
المشكله
المنظومه منظومه التعليميه هي منظومه فيها
شركاء فيها المدرسه فيها ولي الامر وفيها
الطالب فاذا اذا المدرسه عندها توجه ورؤيه
معينه انه نهتم بالقراءه والكتابه يعني
مثلا قلت مثلا امور جميله من الكتاب يعني
المدرسه يوم تدرس والطالب يعني نعطيه
الكتاب ويعلم على الكتاب الام في البيت
تقدر ترجع الى الدرس الاول بسهوله وببساطه
وتشوف التع اللي مكتوبه والتصليحات اللي
مكتوبه هاي نقطه مهمه
الكتاب والمنهج مش محصور بكتاب معين يؤدي
الى الضياع
امر بعد ترى الطفل معلومات المعلومات
المعلوماتيه عنده اعلى بكثير من نحن
وقدراتنا سبحان الله بالطبيعه يعني
فاكيد انه انا بتوفق
شكرا جزيلا لك الحديث يعني يطول حول هذا
الموضوع رئيسه مجلس اداره مدرسه دبي كرمله
دكتوره مايا الهواري شكرا
يعطيك العافيه اهلا وسهلا لمتابعتي المزيد
من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات